[Music]
i'd love for you
to
explain who don valentin
is
and
we're gonna
we're gonna explore that a bit but
uh
could you also explain what his 2x2
matrix was
so don valentine is one of the fathers
of
silicon valley one of the fathers of
venture capital
don grew up in the semiconductor
business he was a national and fairchild
semiconductor back in the 1960s and he
started sequoia capital in 1972
and
we should get back to this later but he
made a very important decision calling
it secure capital and not valentine
capital
don had an amazing career as an investor
he
backed apple
when a lot of people were unsure about
backing a barefooted not well-dressed
steve jobs
he backed atari he backed ea he backed
oracle cisco and the list goes on he had
a remarkable track record as an investor
and when i joined sequoia he was
still around still alive he passed away
two years ago
and very early on he pulled me aside and
he said uh there's a two by two matrix
of people we get to invest in
exceptional not exceptional
uh easy to get along with not so easy to
get along with your job to date relife
is to figure out in which of those four
quadrants we normally make money
so i
i have not heard this story i don't know
the answer i i could hazard a guess but
why don't why don't you
tell us number one did you figure it out
and what is the answer
i think you have an intuition for it
it's you know exceptional not so easy to
give along with
and the reason it's you know when you
think about the
the founder
prototype or you know personality type
you know most of us encounter challenges
in the world and we just let it go
you know this is difficult this doesn't
work this frustrates me and you just go
ah whatever and you move on to the next
thing founders are these people who
don't take no you know they don't accept
the way the world is they want to change
it they encounter a frustration
and they do something about it but going
back to the cisco example right the
founders of cisco were the heads of the
computer departments for computer
science and the business school at
stanford and they were on different
networks so they could send primitive
electronic mail within departments but
not across campus and the two of them
were romantically involved and we're
getting tired of walking across campus
to see each other they want to do i'm
not kidding you this is the like the
first international story it's great
this is fantastic yeah and so the
founding inspiration for cisco was
connecting the networks of the computer
science and business schools at
stanford and that's the founding story
right instead of just accepting the
status quo and so there's so many other
companies we're back with this is the
example right jack and and jim started
square because there was a lost sale i
mean these personal frustrations are
just incredibly powerful so when you
think about a person who wants to take
on the world and doesn't just accept it
that tells you a lot
about what the founder is like
right and they're highly likely to push
back on on
that i would imagine that they don't
feel is fully aligned with the change
that they want to
leave in the world or
in part to the world
what are some other characteristics
that could be related to the exceptional
not so easy to get along with or they
could be separate
that you have identified within the data
set of
hits from sequoia
where you've made money and by you i
mean sequoia
well first it starts with an authentic
identification with a problem
i think that that founding inspiration
because if you if you're trying to start
a business for the sake of starting a
business
it's it's so hard
there are so many challenges on the on
the way to building a successful company
if you're doing it for the wrong reasons
you're going to wilt
you you simply won't persevere but if
you're deeply motivated by what you're
doing you'll keep going and you'll
overcome obstacle after obstacle and so
that to me is one of the key starting
conditions is
founder market fit found a problem fit
what you know i love asking a founder
and i meet them like how did you come up
with this idea
like what was the eureka moment where
something snapped and you want to do
to address this problem and what is it
about the current solutions that you
must have evaluated that frustrated you
that you didn't think was good enough
and then the next one is what's your
unique and compelling value proposition
so having evaluated alternatives and
deciding to build something why do you
think what you're building is so
distinct that it has a chance of
flourishing and becoming a real business
so i can tell you one specific story
there's a founder matra binovitz he and
i met in high school
in south africa in 1987 at a nerd camp
uh it was actually called an academic
vacation school but i mean that's just a
very nice way of saying
and
he's absolutely brilliant he was gold
medalist in our national science
olympiad he came to stanford he studied
physics electrical engineering and in
2002 his sister had a baby that died
within a week of birth
and he was shocked at the state of
prenatal testing
and he went back to stanford and he
learned everything he could about
biology and genetics and started this
company natera
where i'm still on the board 15 years
later we made a million dollar seed
investment in him in 2006 just an idea
and today they they deliver millions of
tests
to help people have healthy families
but it started with an incredibly
authentic inspiration for him which is
seeing what his sister had to deal with
you know i've never heard
the
elegance of this phrase you used before
the founder problem fit but
and i am just a
tourist in the startup world compared to
your immersion as an entrepreneur
operator and investor but if i look back
at all of the angel investments i've
made
the founder problem fit is the defining
feature of any of the hits
not
product market fit which may also exist
but in terms of
the hierarchy of weighted importance
it's this founder problem fit that's a
fantastic phrase
what else have you learned or did you
learn
rather from don valentin and it could
just be anything that you observed in
him attribute behavior habit or
otherwise but what are some of the
takeaways
from having spent time with him
incredibly good listener
you think about the
stereotype maybe of an investor who's
fast talking and needs to be heard
don was very comfortable sitting for an
hour and just listening
and absorbing and then he was very
precise with his questions precise with
his notes i remember
receiving a note in my inbox from don
i was confused initially because there
was no to or from so i didn't know who
it was you know who'd written me this
note
so i walked around the office saying you
know who left this for me and people
looked at it and said
it's written in green ink
it's done
[Laughter]
so donna had exclusive use of green ink
in the office no one else was allowed to
use a green pen he loved the color of
money
but he would take a full page and there
maybe be ten words in the page
and they just they were just so
incredibly concise in describing the
feedback that he wanted to give about a
company or when he interviewed people i
saw some of his interview notes about
people
you know instead of writing two pages of
notes about the interview he was just so
crisp and on the point and so his
ability to distill things very concisey
is incredible
you